players of Resident Evil 5 on ps4 and
Xbox one are currently experiencing some
issues I'm Lucy and welcome to Oh
seriously it's great in co-op games for
news updates
players have reported framerate drops in
addition to glitches with some of the
game modes and ii players inventory
screen some players have reported that
player 2 can't buy upgrade weapons in
between chapters either capcom has
confirmed in a statement to GameSpot
that it's working on Resident Evil 5
issues we are aware of the current
performance issues and certain gameplay
bugs and the team is currently looking
into it there's no word yet on when a
fix will be available president evil 5
is the second Resident Evil game to be
released on the current generation of
platforms this year
Resident Evil six landed in March while
Resident Evil 4 is scheduled for fall so
we finding problems with resi 5 on ps4
and Xbox one let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games for more on Resident
Evil make sure you keep a game spark